must be a big day at NATO if you're all
of if all of you are here
not only is it the birthday of the
Washington treaty but also big day for
Finland
and we sincerely congratulate our
Finnish friends with the accession
Ukraine is aiming at
reaching the same goal becoming a full
member of NATO and it will be one of the
topics of our conversations here in
Brussels of how can we move forward
NATO and Ukraine need each other as
simple as that and while we appreciate
the Practical support we receive from
the alliance there is no
better strategic solution to ensuring
six strategic Security in the
euro-atlantic region than the membership
of Ukraine in their eyes so thank you